Guten Tag.
Alle ist mein Name.
Ich bin Diensthabendeart.
Bevor wir über Ihre Beschwerden sprechen,
würde ich Ihnen gerne ein paar Personen,
besorgenden Fragen stellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, klar, natürlich.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Helga Hagen.
Helga Hagen, H-E-L-G-A.
Okay, und nachher?
Hagen, H-A-G-E-N.
Okay, ich bin eine Frau.
Ich bin eine Frau.
Danke.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin, wer jetzt denn ist, 60.
Ich bin am 18. Mai 1963 geboren.
18. Mai 3 und 63.
60, okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,63 m steht in meinem Ausweis.
Wie viel wegen Sie?
80 kg.
Vielen Dank für die Informationen, Frau Hagen.
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe ganz heftige Bauchschmerzen,
hier oben im Bauch.
Das kommt mit so Wellen,
da krampft sich alles zusammen.
Ich habe noch ein paar Sachen zu tun.
Heute Morgen,
späten Vormittag, hat das angefangen.
Wir hatten einen Sektempfang bei meinem Mann im Büro.
Da gab es so Häppchen,
Champagner und Sushi.
Ich weiß nicht, ob da irgendetwas nicht in Ordnung war.
Aber mit allem ging das los,
da gab es so viele Schmerzen.
Mir ist unheimlich schlecht.
Ich musste mich übergeben.
Da ist das ganze Zeug wieder rausgekommen.
Es war ganz schlimm.
Ich fühle mich gräßlich schlecht.
Ich habe heftige Schmerzen.
Ich verstehe, Frau Hagen.
Könnten Sie mir sagen,
ob Sie die Schmerzen haben?
Oberhalb des Bauchnabels,
quer rüber.
Sind die Schmerzen langsam
oder plötzlich begonnen?
Sie sind richtig schnell gekommen.
Mit einem Finger fangen Sie das an.
Könnten Sie mir sagen,
wie können Sie
die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind die Schmerzen
eher domverdrückend?
Es ist ganz starker Druck.
Wie kann man das beschreiben?
Das kramft sich so alles zusammen.
Ich verstehe.
Frau Hagen,
sind Sie diese Schmerzen ausgetragen?
Braucht ihr Medikamente?
Ich habe versucht, das zu nehmen.
Aber das ist sofort wieder rausgekommen.
Wenn wir nicht lange brauchen,
können Sie mir hinterher Medikamente geben.
Frau Hagen,
ich habe eine Frage.
gibt es etwas auslesen
für die Schmerzen?
Ich nehme an,
dass dieses Essen bei dem Sektempfang war.
Könnten Sie wiederholen?
Es gab da Sushi
und so kleine
Häppchen,
Kanapäse
mit
Aufschnitt
und Käse.
Ich habe gar nicht so viel gegessen.
Wenn ich jetzt nur an diese Fischgeschichten denke,
es wird mir ganz schlecht.
Ich verstehe.
Frau Hagen,
haben Sie Schmerzmixell eingenommen?
Ich habe versucht,
Ibuprofen einzunehmen.
Aber ich habe mich dann sofort hinterher wieder übergeben.
Und dann war natürlich alles wieder weg.
Okay.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen
auf einem Sektempfang?
Ich habe Schmerzen auf einem Sektempfang.
Wenn die Schmerzen auf einem Sektempfang sind,
dann ist das sicherlich bei 8 bis 9.
Und strahlen die Schmerzen
in den anderen Sektempfang?
Ja, stimmt.
Wo Sie fragen,
wie hoch ist die Schulter?
Rechte Schulter.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und könnt ihr Sie bitte sagen,
ich habe nicht ganz gut verstanden.
Rechte Oberbrauch
oder linke Oberbrauch?
Ich würde sagen,
der ganze Oberbrauch quer rüber.
Also praktisch unterhalb der Brust,
oberhalb des Names, das tut alles weh.
Aber es strahlt so nach rechts oben.
Ja, ganz.
Haben Sie diese Schmerzen früher gehabt?
Ne, solche Schmerzen hatte ich nicht.
Was mir aufgefallen ist,
im Rückblick,
dass ich schon seit längerer Zeit
so nach Fettigem Essen ein bisschen Probleme hatte.
Und dass ich auch häufiger mal Durchfall hatte.
Und das ist mir eigentlich
in letzter Zeit sowieso nicht so wahnsinnig gutgegangen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt so da drin sich
irgendwie zugespitzt hat.
Normalerweise bin ich ganz gesund.
Ich habe überhaupt nichts.
Aber ich habe immer noch etwas,
ich bin ganz gesund.
Ich habe überhaupt nichts.
Aber das ist jetzt mit einmal,
dass es mir richtig schlecht geht.
Okay, Frau Hagen.
Und haben Sie Feber?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, glaube ich, aber nicht.
Und haben Sie Nachschweiß oder Schüttelfrost?
Nein, nein.
Ich habe keine Nachschweiß oder Schüttelfrost.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Eigentlich ist der gut.
Aber jetzt im Augenblick darf ich überhaupt nicht als Essen denken.
Okay.
Und haben Sie in letzter Zeit Abwörter zugenommen?
Nein, leider nicht abgenommen.
Nein, hier habe ich nicht.
Ich frage mich.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Meistens schon, ja.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Schwindelig?
Nein, schwindelig ist mir nicht.
Okay.
Vielen Dank, Frau Hagen.
Leitern Sie an chronische Vorerkrankungen?
Ich sage zu euch, ich bin ganz gesund.
Ich habe nie irgendetwas gehabt.
Deswegen wundert mich, dass so etwas jetzt los ist.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder gelegentlich Medikamente?
Nein, ich nehme eigentlich gar nichts.
Manchmal, wenn ich so ein bisschen Wagenkremfe habe,
dann nehme ich mal so eine Magnesium-Tablette.
Aber das ist auch alles.
Sonst nehme ich gar nichts.
Ich war immer stolz, wie fit ich war.
Gegen Magenkremfe oder?
War denn kremfe?
War dann okay.
Ich verstehe, okay.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, als Kind habe ich die Mandeln rausbekommen.
Und dann hat man mir vor 10 Jahren die Gebärmutter entfernt,
weil ich da Myoma hatte.
Aber das war auch das 1-Gemalt,
weil ich noch ein bisschen Gesundheitsprobleme hatte.
Und noch weitere Operationen?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergie?
Ja, man hat mal festgestellt,
dass ich eine Nickelallergie habe.
Dass ich also mit Metallknöpfen
und etwas,
etwas, was ich so ganz einfachen bestecke.
Oder so muss ich ein bisschen Kontakt meiden.
Und natürlich auch mit Modischmuck und so.
Wie äußert sich dieser Allergie?
Ja, dann kriege ich da an den Kontaktstellen
so trockene, schubbige rote Haut und das juckt.
Rote Haut und juckt.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ich bin vollständig geimpft, ja klar.
Ich mache eine gegen Kinderkrankheiten und auch Corona.
Ja, Kinderkrankheiten ist ja schon lange her,
aber gegen Corona bin ich auch geimpft.
Ja, und ich glaube, sonst ist auch alles so,
was man so haben muss, da achtet mein Haus aus.
Okay, vielen Dank Frau Argen.
Und rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, hin und wieder trinke ich ein Glas Sechst.
Ja, das passiert schon so, zwei bis dreimal in der Woche.
Ja.
Zwei bis dreimal.
Okay, nehmen Sie bitte nicht persönlich.
Ich muss diese Frage stellen.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Nein, mit Drogen habe ich keinen Kontakt.
Okay, ich habe vergessen, diese Frage.
Wie ist er?
Oder haben Sie Probleme mit Stuhlgang oder ein Wasser lasse?
Ja, beim Stuhlgang, da sagte ich,
dass ich schon längere Zeit leicht mal Durchfall habe.
Und beim Wasserlassen, da ist mir tatsächlich in letzter Zeit aufgefallen.
Entschuldigung, in letzter Zeit ist mir aufgefallen,
dass der Urin ungewöhnlich dunkel ist.
Okay.
Und wie häufig müssen Sie auf die Toilette gehen?
Ja, manchmal zwei, dreimal am Tag, aber das ist nicht immer Durchfall.
Das ist dann mal fest und mal ist es so dunkel.
Okay.
Und haben Sie dunkle Urinenwasser lassen?
Nein, das sah ein bisschen dunkler aus als normalerweise.
Okay.
Und Frau Hagen, wie ist Ihr Freundinstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Töchter, aber die sind natürlich erwachsen und aus dem Haus.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, zum Glück ja, natürlich.
Ja, gut.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwister.
Mit wem leben Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Mit meinem Mann. Die Kinder sind wie gesagt aus dem Haus.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, die leben noch, aber die sind beide,
die sind natürlich nicht so ganz auf dem Damm mehr.
Mein Vater hatte einen Schlaganfall und lebt im alten Heim,
der es auf dem Rollstuhl angewiesen.
Meine Mutter hat eine kleine Wohnung da ganz in der Nähe.
Die lebt aber noch alleine, aber die hatten so ein Altersdiabetes.
Und muss regelmäßig Medikamente nehmen, ist da aber eigentlich ganz gut eingestellt.
Und deswegen will die auch noch nicht in das Altenheit ziehen.
Nur Diabetes leidet sich?
Genau. Bitte?
Ihre Mutter leidet ihre Mutter nur an Diabetes?
Ja, das ist das eigentlich, was ich weiß.
Okay, Fragen.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ja, ich leite eine kleine Galerie hier in der Stadt.
Was für ein Galerie?
Eine Kunstgalerie.
Wir machen Ausstellungen und verkaufen und sehr schöne Arbeit.
Das heißt, Sie sind in Künstl, oder?
Nein, ich verkaufe Kunst.
Verkaufe.
Und stelle Sie eben aus und biete Künstler an eine Möglichkeit,
dass Sie bei mir haben stellen.
Okay, Frau Hagen, ich bin mit meiner Aufnahmegespräch fertig.
Haben Sie noch Fragen an mich?
Ja, was kann denn jetzt die Ursache sein
für diese krassen, heftigen Schmerzen?
Frau Hagen, ich verstehe Ihre Sorgen,
aber ich kann noch nichts sagen, was Sie haben.
Da ich ja jetzt körperliche Untersuchungen machen müssen,
auch Untersuchungen, zum Beispiel Blutabnahme
oder Ultraschall im Bauch,
dann kann ich genau sagen, was Sie haben.
Okay.
Was machen wir jetzt weiter?
Ja, zuerst wurde ich in einem Körperlemon untersuchern.
Muss ich da wapen?
Nehmen wir die zum Abladen?
Ja, sie sollten oder sie müssen
warten, weil sie haben eine starke Bauchschmerzen
und ich muss ein paar Krankheiten ausschließen,
ob sie ernste Krankheit hat oder nicht.
Alles klar.
Also warte ich jetzt mal auf Sie.
Hallo Kollegen oder Kollegen in Andere Fragen.
Wir müssen einen Punkt finden, da geht es.
Ich denke, alle Fragen sind gestartet,
aber eine kurze Beschreibung
ist, dass es noch ein paar Fragen gibt.
Sie ist andauernd schlecht, sie beklang die Übelkeit.
Sie hat sich drei Mal übergeben
und das waren immer die Essensreste von dem Frühstück.
Vielleicht noch wichtiger, eine Frage.
Hat die Haut sich verändert?
Die Haut?
Die Augen?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Unverträglichkeiten haben wir nicht gefragt.
Er hat nur Allergie gefragt.
Ich habe diese Vergiftung zum Beispiel.
Es gibt auch Fischallergie, aber es ist nicht bekannt.
Keine Ängste.
Keine Unverträglichkeit.
Ich denke, alle Fragen sind gestartet.
Das ist gut.
Können wir als erstes ein Anfang?
Eine Minute.
Alle sind eine Gastroenterologie.
Lief ihm nur zu sagen, das besser.
Deswegen eine leichte Situation.
Ich weiß das ja vorher nicht.
Die haben nicht gewusst.
Ich habe ein paar Verdachtdiagnose, aber ich weiß nicht,
welche.
Es ist ein altbekanter Düsseldorferfall.
Alle Düsseldorfer haben den schon x-mal wieder gekaut.
Wie gucken wir, ob wir im Arzt-Arzt-Jetbretien drauf sind?
Guten Tag.
Ich möchte Ihnen gerne die Patienten Frau Hagen vorstellen.
Sie ist 60 Jahre alt.
Sie ist 1,63 m groß und 60 kg schwer.
80?
80 kg.
Sie stellt sich bei uns,
dass Sie sich bei uns auf die Schmerzen aufgetreten haben.
Seit heute Vormittag,
die Patientin berichtet,
dass die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten sind
und zusätzlich teilt sie mit,
dass die Schmerzen 8 oder 9 auf einer Skala seien.
Die Patienten sind entfernt,
die Folgendes Begleit-Symptome aufgefallen.
Hat sie irgendetwas gesagt, was Auslöser sein könnte?
Auslöser nach Essen.
Was hat sie gegessen?
Sushi und Sekt.
Sushi.
Diese Schmerzen seien nahrungsabhängig,
besonders nach Sushi.
Sie klagt über auch Erbrochen.
In der vegetative Anemnese
bis seit heute Appetitlosigkeit
und Diode
uns auch dunkle Wasser lassen.
Und auch Ruhin.
Und in Erkrankungen
sind bei der Patientin bekannt
und auch Medikamente,
nehme die Patientin keine Medikamente ein.
Es wurde bei der Patientin,
als sie Kind war,
Transylaktomie und wegen Miohne
Historektomie durchgeführt.
Wann war die Historektomie?
Ich habe vergessen.
Miohne Historektomie gibt es,
aber ich habe nicht eine.
Sie haben es entfernt.
Vor zehn Jahren hat sie gesagt.
Sie hat gesagt, Historektomie, nicht Miohnektomie.
Sie hat gesagt, Historektomie wegen Miohne.
Die Patientin sei allweglig auf Nikkel.
Darauf reagieren
Pruritus und
Eglutem.
Sie sei vollständig geheim.
Sie sei nicht traurig.
Trinken 2-3 Glas Wein
oder pro Woche.
Wie viele Jahre?
Ich habe noch nicht gefragt.
Wie lange wissen wir nicht?
Aktuell trinken sie 2-3 Läsern pro Woche.
So etwas ändert sich im lauflischen Leben.
Ich habe nicht mehr gefragt.
Sie sei verheiratet.
Ich habe gesunde Tochter.
Ich lebe mit meiner Familie.
Ich habe keine Geschwister.
Sie haben Kunstgalerie.
Ich lebe mit meinem Vater.
Ich habe ein Ap Africans erliten.
63-50 cm
auf
Koalistas, Billia, Pancreatitis oder
Noch mal, bitte.
Billia Pancreatitis.
Ach so, okay.
Chin.
Alternativ kommen
folgende
im Betracht
Koalitsystitis
Akute Koalitsystitis
auch Pancreatitis
Carcinoma
und
Koalitis erst mal.
Ja, Koalitis auch.
Und
als erste Masse.
Was macht ihr denn diagnostisch jetzt mit der Patientin?
Ja, zuerst körperliche,
würde ich körperliche Untersuchung machen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ja, zum Beispiel auch zuerst Inspektion,
dann Palpation.
Bei der Palpation
Rechte Oberbauch
oder McBurnie
Zeichen
und
Merfie Entschuldigung
Merfie Zeichen
und
Kulän Zeichen
ja, Kulän Zeichen
aber es ist so wenig bei
Akute Pancreatitis
und
zur weiteren Abklärung
würde ich
Blutabnahme
Blutabnehmen
Was würden Sie für Werte
in Labour bestimmen?
Labour
amylose
und
Blutbild
dann Lebeenzyme
AST
und ALT
Alkalischaospatas
und GGT
amylose und Lipose
und
auch
akute Kulististite
und Bilorubin
genau
auch wegen
Kulistase
weil die Patientin
hat gesagt
sie habe Dunkelurin
das heißt kann es Kulistase sagen
genau
und
aus Labour
Alkalischaospatas
und
Kulidiagnose
so weiter
ich habe es speziell an die Stuhlprobe gedacht
weil sie beschreibt, sie hat Durchfall
und dass man dann guckt ob da irgendwas wächst
ja
ok, dann
machen Sie Ultraschall, ja?
ja und
damit können wir akute Kulististite
auch Bilorubin
auszuschließen
und
können wir
Kolidokalitis
feststellen
ja
und auch können wir damit
Pankreas
darstellen
ja genau
ja, sehr gut, ok
und
ja, was geben Sie der guten Frau
gegen die Schmerzen?
Über Profen
oder Intervenis?
wenn Patient
auch gute Pankreatitis
leider
können wir Traumadol
oder ja
zum Beispiel, die hat ja richtig heftige Schmerzen
also
würden Sie sie auch stationär aufnehmen?
ja, ja
ich wurde stationär
und bekommt die sofort
zwei ordentliche Zugänge
ja, Zugänge, Hydration
und dann bekommen Sie natürlich
die Weißbegänge
Sie bekommen IV, IV
Schmerzmittel
und was Potenziell noch?
große Menge Hydration
weil sie viel verloren hat
und die haben sich nicht verstanden
und das würde man noch machen
Sie berichtet ja von Kremsen
ja, ja
Infusionstherapie
Blutgasanalyse
ich meinte jetzt noch, zur Schmerztherapie
Was würde man noch machen?
Kompel, Hygiosyn
und Spassmolise
einmal natürlich Analyse
aber eben auch Spassmolise
dass die Kremse weniger werden
gut
und ja
wie würde es Potenziell weitergehen?
Was könnte man noch für ein
invasives Verfahren
anstreben?
Man sollte sich meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen
empfehle ich
schlage ich ER, CP
durchführen
und
wenn
oder zuerst können wir auch
endoscopische Ultrasonografie durchführen
dann können wir auch
ER, CP durchführen
sehr gut, okay
gut, ja dann
schauen Sie zu wie es Frau
Hagenweiter geht, halten Sie mich bitte auf den Laufenden
ja und
dann hoff ich
dass es der Patientin bald besser geht
gut
ja
also, keine Frage, Alamese war top
Bericht
würde ich
ein paar Kleinigkeiten
ein paar Kleinigkeiten wirklich nur
ansprechen wollen
also klar, Sie sind keine Frage
natürlich geblieben, ja, was auch immer man gefragt hat
Sie wussten immer alles, ne
kein Ding
aber diese Geschichte
wie es zu den Schmerzen gekommen ist
das ist ja eigentlich so eine klassische Situation
ja, man ist bei einem festlichen Essen
bei einem Empfang und da gibt es was
Besonderes, was man sonst nicht ist
ja und das klang jetzt so
also, ja, Sie hat Bauchschmerzen besonders nach Sushi
das ist immer, wenn sie Sushi ist
kriegt sie Kohlekartige
ja, nee, so ist es ja nicht
sondern sie hat eben einmal zu diesem Deck
empfangen, jetzt seit diesen komischen Ohren Fisch gegessen
ja und
uuh, das ist ihr nun überhaupt nicht bekommen
wie es auch immer das war
ob das eben die blöde
die blöde Galle war, ja
oder ob das
oder ob das tatsächlich eine Fischergiftung war
oder irgendwie
was, was ich ein ganz normales Gastroenterie
ist, weil sie da irgendein Mitgefutter hat
ja, das wissen wir ja nicht
ja und insofern
muss man, finde ich schon
das sehr präzise nochmal nachrag
was haben sie genau gegessen
was, was ich stand das längere Zeit da
zum Beispiel, das wäre vielleicht noch so
ein bisschen, und eben auch in der Schilderung
ganz klar, dieses Essen
dieses Essen war Auslöser
dieses Essen empfand mit
da ist es ja wunderbar, dass man
so schon sieht, der
gute deutsche ist ein Marmeladenbrötchen morgens
ja
oder, oder, was, was ich, Haferflocken
ja, so wie ich, aber man ist ja normalerweise
kein
Sekt und Frühstück am Morgen, ja und das ist
ihr halt nicht bekommen, ja und
sie hat aber durchaus
gesagt, dass sie schon länger
diese Durchfallgeschichten hat und dass sie sich schlapp fühlt
gut, ja
ja, ich kann Ihnen verraten, es war
tatsächlich die akute Kolezistitis
also das ist zumindest die Diagnose die die hier
angegeben haben und
ja
eine Sache noch, Winzigkeit, eine wirklich
Winzigkeit, sie haben gesagt, sie lebt
mit ihrer Familie, sie haben aber vorher
etwas anderes nachgefragt, ich habe gesagt
die Tschechter sind aus dem Haus und sie lebt
mit ihrem Ehemann, ja also
Familie
nicht, sondern die Kinder sind aus dem Haus und sie lebt mit
einem Ehemann, aber sonst, wirklich
alles eins zu eins super wiedergegeben, top
Winsigkeit bedeutet
Was bedeutet?
Ein bisschen klein, ein bisschen klein, ja eine ganz kleinigkeit
Ja, ja, gut
Können Sie damit leben?
Ja, erst mal ein Ehemann
hat er geführt
und das war
erst mal, erst mal
Das war die erste Ahnung am Nese? Ja, erst
ein Ehemann, unglaublich, ja
Super, ja
Gut, nein, also wirklich war richtig gut
diese beiden Kleinigkeiten würde ich sagen
das hätte ich mir ein bisschen anders gewünscht
Gut
Die Patience ist gesagt
Ernste Bescheiden lange Zeit
dann ein bisschen diese Bescheiden
gibt, aber
wenn man das nicht so ganz auf dem Schirm hat,
dass man das so registriert hat
das Problem ist ja
ich bin immer so eine Patientin, die viel redet
und ich gebe Ihnen ganz am Anfang
gebe ich Ihnen viel irgendwo
und dann müssen Sie eigentlich schon ziemlich viel mit schreiben
und sortieren
und dann haben wir das
und dann müssen Sie eigentlich schon ziemlich viel mit schreiben
und sortieren
aber kein Patient wartet,
dass Sie ihm Frage für Frage stellen
der sagt, oh mir ist schlecht, ich habe das und das gemacht
und das ist jetzt und sonst habe ich das nicht
der erzählt Ihnen ja relativ viel auf einmal
ich glaube das ist schon
ich glaube, dass der Patient nur da sitzt
und wartet, dass sie ihn etwas fragen
und nur ja und nein antwortet
das werden Sie selten erleben
wäre vielleicht manchmal einfach
ja ok, nein also
war richtig gut, würde ich sagen
und ja das war dann
jetzt auch unsere letzte Anamnese
für lange Zeit
und das war praktisch den ganzen Monat
ich verabschiede mich bei Ihnen allen
wünsche Ihnen allen
einen gesegneten Ramadan, eine gute Zeit
und
dann sehen wir uns wieder
nach dem Fastenbrechen im April
Dankeschön